[Música]
es hora de repasar la actualidad
económica internacional y para ello nos
acompaña ya en el estudio Juan Pablo
lucumí bienvenido buenos días Rosa Juan
Pablo empezamos con un tema sobre el que
hay comentarios discrepantes no y es que
ayer se reunieron el presidente de
Estados Unidos con Los líderes de la
cámara de representantes y del senado y
hay un poco de ambigüedad sobre cómo se
desarrolló esta reunión Así es rosa pues
le cuento que una de las grandes
conclusiones de las reuniones que
todavía republicanos y la administración
demócrata de Joe biden no se ponen de
acuerdo y esto Es evidente por las
declaraciones que da cada una de las
partes Porque mientras el presidente Joe
biden dice que la reunión fue productiva
los republicanos aseguraron que no hubo
ningún Avance en particular lo dijo el
presidente de la cámara de
representantes Kevin mccarthy esto para
llegar a puntos en común sobre aumentar
el límite de la deuda todo esto a sólo
tres semanas de que el país se vea
obligado a un incumplimiento sin
precedentes y la fecha y el tesoro el
primero de junio es este pues terrible
día que se espera que no llegue
economistas entrevistados por bloomberg
economics ya hablan Que incluso si se
llega a un acuerdo hay muy poco tiempo
en medio para lograr todo el escenario
económico en óptimas condiciones y que
tocaría usar otras alternativas
políticas rápidas para salir bien
librados antes de esta fecha límite
biden incluso dijo ayer que está
considerando usar el de la décimo cuarta
enmienda para este proceso Pero el
tesoro ha dicho que esto traería una
crisis constitucional además de la
crisis política que ya tienen y la
posible crisis económica que se avecina
escuchemos al presidente de Estados
Unidos
en primer lugar acabo de terminar creo
una reunión productiva con los líderes
del Congreso sobre el camino a seguir
para garantizar que Estados Unidos no
incumpla su deuda por primera vez en
nuestra historia me complace pero no me
sorprende Escuchar al líder de La
minoría republicana del senado de
Estados Unidos decir en nuestra reunión
que Estados Unidos no va a incumplir
nunca lo ha hecho y nunca lo hará Y
tiene toda la razón nuestra economía
caería en una recesión significativa
devastaría las cuentas de jubilación
aumentaría el costo de los préstamos
bueno Juan Pablo en todo caso cuando si
hubiera acuerdo lo sabríamos no y cuando
lo haya aseguró que usted o nos los
otros compañeros de economía de France
24 nos lo harán saber pero cambiamos de
información porque el ministro de
finanzas de Perú algunos detalles sobre
la posible adhesión del país a la ocde
fue exactamente Álex Contreras el
encargado de la cartera económica quien
dijo el martes que Perú ha avanzado
bastante bien en la etapa de evaluación
que comprende el proceso de adhesión a
esta organización la llamada
organización para la cooperación y el
desarrollo económico de las diferentes
etapas de adhesión el ministro dijo que
en lo que respecta a la etapa de comités
de las dos evaluaciones que se le hacen
al país Lima ya ha avanzado y reportó
buenos resultados Contreras señaló que
el acceso de Perú a la ocde daría un
mejor escenario para la creación de
políticas públicas la promoción de la
eficacia económica la presencia en los
debates globales así como la llegada de
propuestas con soluciones innovadoras a
problemas financieros del país ya
veremos que suceda en este proceso
veremos Juan Pablo y continuamos en
América Latina porque también hay datos
macroeconómicos de Bolivia ayer
hablábamos de protestas que se daban en
Santa Cruz la ciudad económica de este
país y hoy vamos a a ir continuando en
este escenario financiero del país
porque pues hoy damos a conocer cuánto
creció la economía de Bolivia en 2022
ese país tuvo un crecimiento económico
del 3,5% interanual pero este dato Rosa
no nos dice nada si no lo comparamos
porque estamos hablando de crecimiento
si lo comparamos con el 2021 en realidad
el crecimiento en ese momento fue del
6,1 Entonces aunque un crecimiento del
3,5 pues no se compara con el periodo
del 2021 pese a este crecimiento que se
vio opacado el presidente Luis Arce
declaró lo siguiente y cito a pesar de
todos los intentos internos y externos
de acortar nuestro mandato y de que nos
vaya mal por mezquinos cálculos
políticos aquí estamos firmes para
seguir cumpliendo nuestros compromisos
con el pueblo boliviano esto dijo el
presidente de Bolivia ayer en cuanto a
todo este panorama y también podemos ver
el dato de inflación porque es uno de
los más Bajos en la región pero luego
tenemos que compararlo igualmente porque
decimos un 2,53% de Bolivia Comparado
con Colombia que es un 12 decimos es muy
bajo pero si lo comparamos con abril de
2022 era un de un 0,87% Y usted puede
ver la línea de tendencia que Pues en
realidad ha ido al alza claro Juan Pablo
y no sé si me equivoco pero 2021 fue un
año de mucho crecimiento para muchos
países en comparación con 2020 y la
pandemia No a lo que le llama el efecto
rebote precisamente y Juan Pablo vamos
ahora al continente africano porque
zimbabue quiere impulsar una moneda
digital esta moneda digital fue lanzada
casi un año después que el país sacara
monedas de oro para estabilizar su
moneda que se devalúa rápidamente esto
con la fuerza que coge el dólar en
diferentes temporadas y esas son las
imágenes que vamos a ver o estamos
viendo en este momento respaldada por
una cierta cantidad de oro que ayuda
pues a mantener el valor estable esta
moneda está vinculada al valor de
Mercado del Oro A diferencia de una
moneda fiduciaria se utilizará como
moneda de curso legal y una reserva de
valor junto con el dólar zimbabuense y
los bonos de zimbabue los usuarios
podrán comprarla y venderla usando
dólares sin badenses y otras monedas
extranjeras recordemos que de forma
ideal respaldar una moneda digital con
oro implica tener una cierta medida de
reservas de oro y depende del valor de
Mercado actual del Oro Los tokens
digitales respaldados por oro de
zimbabue tienen un periodo de
adquisición de adquisición perdón de 180
días y tiene un estado activo prescrito
y también pueden ser usados por ejemplo
como para garantía de préstamos bueno
seguro nos informarán de cómo avanza
esta este experimento está esta idea y
vamos ahora con indicadores Juan Pablo
empezamos con América Latina porque las
bolsas en nuestra región cerraron mixtas
con Brasil y Argentina con ganancias por
encima del 1% mientras Perú y chile
cerraron en números rojos Elisa de chile
cayó un menos
1,04% arrastrado por el comportamiento
de los sectores de servicio de
comunicaciones bienes de consumo básicos
y bienes inmobiliarios en Asia las
bolsas cerraron con leves pérdidas sin
arriesgarse mucho antes de conocer el
dato de inflación de Estados Unidos que
pronto estaremos aquí revisándolo